ich sehe dich hätte die blumen an guckst
du
ich habe schon abgebrochen denen der
lieblingsfarbe weg grün ja aber ich hab
nur irgendwie wolle die rolle gerne
haben ich brauche es nicht
ich bin hier draußen bei den bäumen und
fahrkarten um die bäume ab muss verletzt
und fallen einbauen gegentreffer ab
sofort die jetzt echt nicht so schön
egal was spieler ausholte umgebaut
jetzt kann ich die rolle nicht
einsammeln shakir gebäude konfiszieren
außerdem ein wenn die kiste ich habe die
momente wo bist du aber es da wäre es
gleich ein lava sie rein
nein bin so kurz davor ein stab osterloh
starb das waren halt
neues jahr neues thema warum macht ihr
eigentlich videos was motiviert euch bei
der ganzen sache ultra noob 1337 alter
was ein name allein schon weil man nur
solche namen lesen muss nachtmann ein
ultrabook nicht gegen dich weil diese
schöner name
ihre kehlen habe okay alles zum thema
fand ich war bisher immer angefangen zu
labern
naja weil weil es spaß macht
fragezeichen weil die community da auch
ganz gut mitmischt ihr seht mal hier ich
kann kaum auf wenn mitbauen ich muss ich
schon zwingen länger zu machen
recht keinen spaß machen würde dann
würden das land bringen oder ja genau
es ist aber ich trinke ich schon zum
weiter oder länger aufnehmen ist so
glaube ich habe noch immer spaß ich mehr
spaß am spielen wenn ich währenddessen
irgendwelche weiß dass ich irgendwas
quatschen und das seiner nach ein paar
leute anschauen
ich glaube ich hätte auch keine
motivation wenn ich wirklich jetzt immer
noch in über 100 abonnenten hängen würde
aber man muss diese motivation am anfang
einfach aufbringen man muss dann ist das
teilen muss man praktisch macht aber was
bei mir mittlerweile der fall ist ich
mache viel viel über twitter projekte
als so welche sachen also als irgendwie
jetzt so singleplayer display oder so
was euch fertig wird da kann man nur
über themen reden ohne dessen konkreter
konnte das leder wieder als eine frage
gestellt der illuminati vielleicht liegt
die computersucht auch bei der vinci von
damals hatte das ganze etwas mit jesus
christus zu tun packen wir einfach
einmal abdallah oder so das ist der von
galileo die frage war was motiviert
durch videos
ich habe damals eines muss man erstmal
wie man darauf wieso man überhaupt
anfängt sich bestimmt die auch schon zum
tausendsten mal haben wir leute nicht
gewähren nicht gehört oder ja noch nicht
gesehen gehört whatever weil ich dachte
sonst werde ich nie minecraft spielen
ohne mir dauernd alles zu bieten wenn
man sich aufnimmt dann kann man nicht
schieben weil sonst wie sollst du
plötzlich 26 tnt habe ich gefunden habe
ich eigentlich angefangen und dann halt
so den jahren einfach spaß also warum
spielt man fußball spaß bringt wenn man
gewinnen will natürlich spaß bringt
gewinn will ja ob du hier bist und nicht
so genutzt aber auch eine
sicherheitsschleuse dass das jetzt
einfach was für eine sicherheitsschleuse
er dieser gang nicht davor gemacht habe
bei den schafen und so dass wenn man
rausgeht und noch weiter dass sie dann
einen nicht alle hinterher kommt was
eigentlich total unnötig das lasse ich
jetzt auf ich finde einfach ist es ein
guter ansporn wenn man weiß wenn die
tiere aufnimmt und weiß dass gucken sich
nachher echt tausende von leuten an das
ist ein ganz anderes gefühl als wenn man
nicht weiß ob sich das eine anguckt ich
finde hier nur das macht das ging wie so
witzig an den ganzen sache dass man dann
auch auf die community eingehen kann
sich da vorschläge holt zum beispiel
themenvorschläge worüber wir diskutieren
das find ich total interessant machen
ich bin noch da ja ich war nur gerade
konzentrierten ihm ein dass man ja so
dass auch mal gesehen 17 minuten da du
hast schon so viele singles als vorhin
oder fünf wie du dein haus ist er
eigentlich schon fertig ich helfe dir
sogar mit deiner rolle die er nicht will
hast du schon wieder abgebaut da war ich
gar nicht drin ist aber offen doch mehr
einzubringen wollen alles mögliche nach
ist halt den us teil
jetzt lässt sich schnell etabliert er
unter meinen videos konz teile irgendwie
so weil sie zu alter alter geht nur den
nachteil ist so kainz teilhaben
das gilt ich hab' ich chips teil und das
geld weil das was denn so gefällt so
gefällt ich dachte dass er diese
tintenfische zeugs und damit kann hier
sein schwein schaf und so eben nicht ein
schwarzes schaf machen die in die
familie gegen neuere wolle
hofer die lava ich habe noch nicht den
kreisen
auch internetwahlen sitzt man alle
presse sind sie echt voll schön aus ich
dachte ganz hat jetzt der natur naturell
was hat ist es hier einen kräfte am werk
was dann hat er sie erzählen der wald
ist nicht allgemein voll geil gewalt
ich habe nein das wollte ich nicht junge
däne
das wollte ich mal soll die scheiße alte
ich nicht eingesammelt ja aber noch jung
ich war das ist richtig scheiße weil
jetzt habe ich das xperia will nicht
mehr aufweist wie würdest du weiß nicht
12 oder sogar drei zahlen ist nichts wo
ich auf jeden fall alter so viel monster
richter getötet habe ich kann laufen
aber gucken wie viel ich hatte dann
stetig
nein halt stopp ja aber dann darf sich
jetzt auch töten als ausnahme das nicht
dass ich das unfair
das ist das modell wenn du mich tötet ja
es ist wäre fair aber das nein nein nein
einfach überhaupt nicht alle wieder
sicher ich geb dir wirklich ich geb dir
dafür was von mir ich geb dir was von
mir was ich hier habe ich habe tolle
orange wolle wo bist du da ich traue mir
nicht so nah dran an dich ich bin aber
getötet
ja und dann hab ich dich nicht getötet
also sind wir jetzt erst wird jetzt sind
ihr sie sind jetzt erst widmen
ich hatte sieben xp level alles tot
alles beck wieder an experten alles tot
komplette experto de la gare für minuten
auch nicht immer bei dir eben vorbei zu
denen schwert von dem ich weiß nicht
woher das kommt
wie wild haben ich war kurz auf level 8
fast als ich deinen song hatte die
orange wolle sich noch gut aus finde ich
auch
ich sehe ich hätte die blumen
siehst du mich noch wie wir dann aber
ich finde dich durch die blätter durch
ich habe keine ahnung was ihr da macht
es ziemlich kw open an
ich kann ja ich kann nicht mal weg und
alles mögliche machen das ist blöd
bücherregale werden geil gewesen
kühlschrank wir noch nicht ein bisschen
dafür 18
warum auch nicht aus waging wäre ich
also von einem steckt drin aber kein
werkzeug gefragt wieso was das klappt
hier so 23 minuten smartphones co cio
yamaha music video blockade müsste
hinten raus gehen ach ja was weiß ich
wieder da hier folgt die nachmacher du
musst du musst immer noch solche
pflanzen denn nur was essen ja und zwar
jetzt immer was ich mache den beat beat
wir haben ja sowieso wieder ihr könnt
jetzt eine rundtour durchs haus machen
für mehr zeit reichlich wird gern noch
viel mehr ausbauen da hinten werden
bücherregale angebracht werden kann
wieder gehen das ist ja voll peinlich
sein haus ist dass sein haus werde nicht
bezahlt hast du im mitmach steel europe
paysafecard wackeln welt das nach dem
comic strafsachen oben auf und zuklappen
dass er interessante ja okay gut
wir gehen mal ganz kurz hier rein macht
das eigentlich ja hier hätte ich noch
wirklich noch bis optimieren schaut euch
um
ja ja wir offen eine art kleiner junge
hier haben wir ihre rock-band und kisten
was zu essen aber ein paar äpfel sieht
schon ziemlich schön aus muss ich
gestehen
ja ja ja ja es hätte noch mehr gemacht
werden sollen aber wenn und täglich ein-
oder so wir gehen nach oben hier oben
sehen ich hätte die rolle gegeben
du hast meine orangene wolle noch am
stege geben hierzu geworfen also hier
oben haben wir also das schlafzimmer des
juniors serie gebaut werde auf jeden
fall da oben bin ich nicht wer
verantwortlich dass die schweiz wolle
die hat hier wollen gemacht was die hier
ja ach so ich dachte ich könnte mir so
mitnehmen
nein nein die haben wir dann das bett da
schwebt luca über dem dena bett machen
und crafter immer dünner
bettwäsche logisch wäre jeder haben
liegt darin den betfair schlecht auf
dich drauf schlagen sogar kurz im
fanshop nicht nicht nicht selber
entdeckt hat das den abflug ja das war
dann so das haus von spa kopien von
auslaufen
da kam aufs dach da wie auch die
frontansicht des moment so halb so wild
ist fast wäre also wieder von vorne
drauf guckt ist fast fertig ich bin
gerade auf dem dach top drei sind was
willst du im dachgeschoss fein auf dem
holz und selber bruch gekommen
auf mich zu schlagen muss man fertig ja
schlag
nein ich habe keinen ich habe keine
waffe ist ok ich gleich jetzt schlafen
damit am nächsten wenn wir die folgenden
tag ist nein ich komme schafe am ende
die halt mal ein achtes mal schlafen
danach noch verschlafen
wenn aber das kann ja nicht schlafen
drehte heute hatten wir haben ein bett
gebaut
wieso muss es nicht zu dass zwei sachen
und machen keine zu steil
graf das teil
kontra stress kapseln
moment moment contractors teil in meinem
haus okay gut ich würde sagen wir werden
die folge weil wir sind schon über 2
stunden
danke wieder an alle personen die uns
irgendwie themen die kommentare
geschrieben haben und auch danke an alle
personen die die videos mal so fleißig
bewährten danke ans bartlos phoenix der
hier zu gast war danke an den er dafür
dass er immer noch hier leider zu gast
ist schluss habe ich auch gekillt ich
wollte seine ex ph ja man selbst der
wallstreet xp und ich will denen das xp
nein das tust du das tust du nicht dass
du so einen jungen bett ist was missing
abstraktes habt ihr dann auch zerstörten
umgesetzt jetzt bin ich in europa auf
der welt egal ist eine zone team mates
auf jeden fall
ich würde sagen gesetzt dann beim
nächsten mal nein nein nein das nicht
eigentlich hätte ich könnte die richtig
auf ich höre auf und anleger auf mich
zuerst auf ich hoffe du wirst auf ich
hoffe du als auch ich auf und wurde
abschließend feedback zum haus geben ich
find ich finde es auch schön ich finde
die frontansicht sehr gelungen dass das
ist das das schönste haus bis jetzt hier
ich werd ich finde ich jetzt eigentlich
auch ganz schön hat spaß weil es blöd
aber ich würde erstmal sagen danke ans
park dank an die zuschauer und dann
würde ich sagen sie
in der nächsten folge des kassenverbands
um zwanzig nach ihrem tod in space
die pads sind weg nein man man da gibt 1
und die sind spinnen bei mir ich dürfe
jetzt hier hormann die habe ich aus dem
sumpf geholt außerdem habe ich dich gar
nicht getötet das war den nein das steht
im chat spark auf wenig was lane bei
concordia okay gut bis zum nächsten mal
schießt sondern aber generell ist man
aus feucht aufnahmestopp